so why is a mother's role so crucial
for the first three years of their child's development
well according to Doctor Erica Commissar
the first three years is the most critical time for right brain development
the right brain has many roles
some of the most important being emotional regulation
resilience to stress
and can dictate how a child trust people and dictates their future relationships
she claims that we have created two to three generations of people
unable to form proper attachments and create proper relationship
and unknowingly Gen Zers
Gen Xers and millennials were the Guinea pigs
the Guinea pigs of modern feminism
saying that women had to go back to work after they had a baby
that millions of us have now
because of how our relationship to our mother was
in our first three years of development
one of the researchers that she interviewed for her book
says that women were meant to be the central nervous system of a child
within their first three years
cause as we all already know now
babies and young toddlers are incapable of regulating their emotions
so they have to have you as a mom help them regulate
you know we all started talking recently about the fourth trimester
this is your postpartum state
but it also has a lot to do with child development
there's a theory that says
children were not supposed to be born for at least another nine months
that the only reason they are
born is because their heads are too large for us to physically hold anymore
just like a carry primate
just like a koala bear and a gorilla
and a panda bear every primates always have their babies attached to them
the first year of your child's life
should be worn by a mom or close to her at almost all times
and this is part of their development
just as it would still be developing inside your in utero
and without these critical two to three years with your child
we have formed three known attachment disorders
No. 1 insecure attachment
No. 2 reactive attachment disorder or R a d
and No. 3 disorganized attachment
stay tuned for my next video
because I will go through each attachment
and how that manifests itself in future relationships when we become adults
let me know in the comments if this interests you
and I will go into further detail